on your screen right now is David Sirota
and here on the screen is his new book
it's called the uprising an unauthorized
tour of the populist revolt scaring
washing Wall Street in Washington mr.
sorta in a kind of modern-day Alexis de
Tocqueville you took off around the
country to listen to Americans before we
get to the how you did it why don't you
tell our audience about your conclusion
and the premise for this book and then
we'll talk more about your means and
methods well when I what I found is that
there's the country's very very angry
and that that anger is translating
itself into activism on both the right
and left and so what I sought out to do
is look at how successful that activism
has been what it might mean for the
future because the real question I say
is that there is an uprising of anger in
the country and then I asked the
question well is that uprising gonna
become a full-fledged social movement
and I didn't actually I wasn't able to
make a conclusion on that I didn't want
to they couldn't look into a crystal
ball but what I said is that there
certainly could be a social movement
that comes out of this and it could be a
conservative social movement it could be
a progressive social movement I tend to
think that that it's more likely that
it'll be a progressive movement that
comes out of this uprising and this
activism but but you know that people
are very excited about the democratic
prospect of Democratic Party prospects
and progressive prospects but as I found
on this on this journey that there's a
whole strand of conservative populism
that that has a lot of traction out
there and and if you look at our
country's history it could go in either
direction we have have historically have
had uprisings throughout our country's
history that that seem like they're
gonna go in one direction and then go in
the entirely opposite direction so we're
really I think at the at the edge here
you chose to put the umbrella of
populism over over this these trends
that happen in the country but that word
itself has a lot of historical meaning
what do you mean by it right it's really
one of these terms it's it's hard to
define there's no actual any one
definition of it what I define it as is
the politics that comes out of a sense
of backlash a sense of anger a sense of
grievance and what I say is that
populist moments tend to happen
at times when what the establishment and
what the people governing on behalf of
the people are doing that is very
different from what the people really
want yeah I mean there's always that
divide in our country but when the gap
becomes really really big that's when
you have these populist moments and
today look we have the country we look
at polls the country's unified against
the Iraq war basically bumped a majority
public opinion against the war for
universal health care for energy reform
cracking down on the oil companies and
you've got a government that is doing
either nothing on those issues or
exactly the opposite and that's why you
have this populist moment Chris when you
get to the secondary level of how do you
do that that's where all the debate
starts that's right that's right how do
you have with any of those policies
right how do you actually address those
policies but I think what's going on now
is we're not even having a debate about
what do you do on those policies right I
mean in the book you'll see on the war
great example you've got a debate in the
Democratic Party not about how to end
the war but as one congressman said a
couple months ago
what kind of Pro Ward Democrat we want
to be which is so there's not even
having a debate really about how to end
the war when the country again look at
public opinion polling is basically
majority public opinion is basically
unified against the war and that's why
you have this upsurge in in anger and
activism and people taking matters into
their own hands I want to give the youth
phone lines so you can join in on this
conversation those of you who are very
much involved in politics a lot of this
will resonate with you 2:02 737 triple
zero one for Republicans our line for
Democrats to zero to 737 triple zero two
independent line here to zero to six two
eight zero to zero five and as I give
out the phone lines I was struck in
reading your book by thinking that at
c-span we have been listening to these
very people for nearly 30 years here
that's a long time in political history
and yet during the course of the 30
years with lots of discontent calling in
and some of them part of movements there
has never been in 30 years a widespread
a social change that has happened
so what much it might be different about
this period in history well what I think
is is that is that that we are we could
be at a moment where the right forces
align
that there are levels of commonality now
across partisan lines a caught across
ideological lines among in the public so
an example trade policy you have as
you'll see in this book you have folks
organizing on the progressive left
through the through for instance the
Working Families Party in New York and
Connecticut effusion party that's
leveraging real power against our
current trade policy you also have the
California Minutemen who I visited who
are also engaging in in a form of
activism ultimately against our
globalization policies now I'm not
making a value judgment whether I agree
with them or agree with the other
example the point is though there is
that commonality and I think that those
commonalities where people are finding
there's potential issues of which the
left and right can get together whether
where they divide is not left and right
it's really what populism has always
been us versus them
the us being the mass public the them
being the establishment pushing these
policies so I think there's really that
possibility how does the ubiquity of the
internet and the widespread use of video
for example so people can illustrate
stories effect this development well
what I say in the book is that the you
know there's a lot of talk online and on
blogs that that that the net roots and
the blogosphere is its own movement or
its own uprising and what I say is
that's kind of silly that's kind of like
saying that telephone users are their
own movement now because the Internet is
just a medium what I say is that the
possibility of what the internet could
do to take this uprising and make it a
full-fledged movement is really that's
where the internet really could be
important it's really it could be the
connective tissue as like as I say in
the book I liken it to it could be it's
sort of the underground newspaper of the
uprising and it could bring people
together in that way our lines are
ringing off the hook not surprising
because this is a topic near and dear to
c-span viewers hearts before we do get
to calls have well you spend a moment
telling our audience a little bit about
yourself and how you got into this sure
I've had a weird trajectory I guess I
came I went to school in Chicago college
at Northwestern and then I worked on a
congressional race there
and I got to get involved in politics oh
boy um it's really just in in college I
decided I worked on a local campaign a
local losing campaign I've learned in
politics that you lose a lot before you
win I worked on a local campaign and
Chicago started out in Chicago politics
first campaign I worked on that one was
Jo huffily congressman from Pennsylvania
he on his fourth try he was running he
won that was my local where I grew up in
the pin Montgomery County Pennsylvania
and then I came to Capitol Hill and I
worked for Bernie Sanders the when he
was a House member and as it relates to
the uprising he's in he's in this book
because he works with talk about
commonalities one of his best allies on
the hill when I worked for him was Ron
Paul
so socialist Bernie Sanders one of his
best legislative allies was Ron Paul so
there's a level of comedy he was really
a master of that commonality kind of
politics and then I worked for the House
Appropriations Committee as a spokesman
for Dave Obie and then I gave me my
whole resume here and then I worked for
the Center for American Progress and
then I went and moved out to Montana
because I in those times had taken some
time off to work for a guy named Brian
Schweitzer who was now the governor of
Montana is a good friend of ours my
families now because we've we've gotten
to know him so well and then we moved
down to Denver and people asked me why'd
you move down to Denver was it because
of the convention or anything like that
I said no no it's actually that's
because my wife is going to a Social
Work school there now listening to that
resume our Republican callers might
suggest well this guy has a political
agenda he wants an outcome here what's
your response to that my response is
that is that what I did in the book was
I said look I'm not gonna pretend that
I'm not progressive right I'm not gonna
do that I'm I'm I believe in what
actually what Lou Dobbs of all people
says and he's in the book to what he
does you know that the he-said she-said
journalism were pretending to be
objective is always the right thing my
feeling was I'll go out and I'll report
the facts and I will say look I am a
progressive I'm not gonna distort the
facts for my agenda and what what you
know one reviewer has already said is
that I quote people accurately and
fairly and then I state my opinion
separately Isle of Palms South Carolina
go ahead please I hate good morning
everyone
David you are so right on the money
there is three things I'd like to say
first of all there are 290 million
Americans across the United States that
are infuriated that this Fiasco with the
banking industry no one is speaking
about there 27 people that it takes to
run to build a home the construction
field have just been hit we were hit
with manufacturing and service being
outsourced by the Republican Ronald
Reagan NAFTA tastic laughter now you're
seeing all this housing loans defaulting
the people had no problem working their
jobs if when you're making eight ten
thousand dollars every month but when
you use seventy six million illegal
slave labor but you have a huge issue
that anger is so great I don't think you
people and the politics realize that we
can freeze corporate assets we can throw
three thousand people out of the offices
that means all the governors that or not
they're sitting there with our hands up
like gee we don't know what to do we the
American people can take our cast-iron
frying pans we don't have to worry about
you all taking our guns away
let me let me interrupt because you're
describing anger and you're saying it's
widespread but the question David Sirota
are you still talking or ulis yes okay
okay the question David Sirota asks is
how to organize that and if the country
is ready to organize that anger into
political action as a matter of fact I
believe that everybody that I speak to
and I get calls because I am in a
construction field from all over the
country it's already occurring you just
have no idea the tenacity and porosity
that is coming alright thank you well my
response is that is that this is a
reflection I think of an accurate
reflection of what's of what's going on
I think that that what we see is is
really people saying that they're really
angry and and and and I think you asked
the right question is is is how does
that all get harnessed and you know I I
my my take is is that you have one of
two outcomes in this uprising
you either have it dissipate into
nothing or you have it organized into
something a well organized
something that that actually
has a structure and and it's an open
question whether that's going to happen
presence of the voice for most of the
discontent been in the the face of third
party politicians over the years and and
if so as does the structure allow for
the success of third party politicians
it's interesting I was on I was attacked
if you go to a Ralph Nader's website
I've been attacked I'm on the front of
his website being at being attacked
because I was on a show and I said I
didn't mention him and that was bad and
third party politics tends to bring when
you talk about it tends to bring out a
lot of emotion in people what I look at
third party politics in one of the
chapters in this book and what I say is
what I conclude is is that is that we've
been deluded into thinking that third
party politics expresses itself and has
expressed itself in the past most
pronounced at the presidential and
federal level when in fact our country's
history of third party politics where
it's really been powerful is at the
local and state legislative level and I
think I'm paraphrasing somebody in the
book the head of the Working Families
Party Dan Cantor says you know third
party politics is a fool's errand
without structural change and what that
means really is is that unless you
change the rules of the game like New
York State and Connecticut and eight
other fusion states which gives more
power to third parties you are
potentially having a fool's errand where
you create either-or choices that tend
to negate what you want to do Asheville
North Carolina for David Sirota you're
on the air yes good morning David you're
the person I've been looking for I blame
the problem that we're in with gasoline
on We the People we are sitting in our
barcaloungers and in our bucket seats
and we just want to think about it we
don't want to get up and do anything
there are three groups experienced in
rebellion now we're all old
the n-double-a-cp the unions and both
baby boomers who rebelled against the
war it would take us a week to get
decent gas prices if we just parked the
big big the big rigs and we drove our
cars into the center of town and wall
staufen left them we would have hardship
for a week but we don't want hardship
we're spoiled to death we want them to
think of what to do and they are getting
exactly what they want they're making
bundles of money and we don't do
anything next week I will make an
appointment with the n-double-a-cp
someone's got to put those three groups
together and we've got to be coordinated
and it doesn't have to act long if all
the big rigs stop well let me let me go
on let me let me respond to it I think
you're you're you make underneath the
issue of oil and gas prices which I I
agree this is a clear populist issue
where you've got you know people charged
being charged high prices at the pump at
the same time ExxonMobil is reporting
forty billion dollars in profits the
most of any corporation in the history
of corporations it's just unfathomable
beneath your point you make the point
that we're waiting for somebody to come
along and fix things and you know Barack
Obama says you know I forget how he puts
it exactly but you know we're waiting
for us well what I think I think even he
misses the point a little bit in that
what we're being told by the media every
single day underneath all the campaign
stories is that the only way to make
change is to engage in presidential
politics when in fact that is not the
history of our country the history of
our country is a history of direct
action people taking matters into their
own hands both in the electoral arena
and in in terms of again direct action
unionizing shareholder activism far away
from presidential politics what I worry
about in this presidential election is
that whoever wins people will say we did
it we made change we voted for the for
whoever we voted for there's a new
president that's it the work is done
that is not how politics works we need
to understand that the election is the
beginning of change if there's going to
be any change not the end candidates
parties and politicians are vehicles for
social movements and uprisings they are
not social uprisings and social
movements themselves do you agree with
her assessment that Americans have
gotten lazy I agree that that that I
wouldn't say it's late
I think Americans feel helpless I think
that and it that's a justifiable feeling
that that that you we feel like we can't
have any access to changing our country
access to the levers of power that we
need to change our country and I think
that's a product of in part a media
again that tells us that the only place
to make change is presidential politics
what's subversive about that message of
course is the messages we all want to
make change and the best place to make
change is presidential politics the
arena that is literally structured most
to resist change on that note let me
show people your list of chapters here
you have a big country out there in a
year to do it how did you choose the
stories that would ultimately end up in
the book it's a good question there's 12
chapters and it could have been 24 or 32
I had to start cutting down he could've
been 50 and it took a long time to
whittle down how am I going to do is
what I looked for where stories that
told other stories stories that
exemplified bigger stories bigger trends
I mean I you know I went out to Seattle
and I looked at people at the union's
that's trying to organize Microsoft
Workers into a union and I chose that
not because that union has had all that
much success and they've been successful
at a local level but they've had trouble
but what I did was I use that cuz it's
an exemplary story of what the
challenges are for the wider bigger
labor movement next phone call for you
unions l Virginia
good morning caller hello I agree with a
lot of what the gentleman is saying as
far there is no prising there is anger
but on the right side we have Newt
Gingrich's plan and here's the thing
that he talked about in his latest book
and I believe one thing is
overwhelmingly important and that is
that our country remains safe and I
believe both parties came together when
they tried to knock on the border issue
but I think he there are many many
people who want us to be protected and
for that reason we need to keep
our troops in Iraq even if it's just to
keep things safe we're in that area and
I think that if there's three about
three million Americans and no one ever
gets them all whenever they go out and
ask about these things and he's probably
wrong on the people who would want to
just quickly stop a war and perhaps put
us in more danger Thank You Koehler
I think the caller's talking about about
right-wing populism conservative
populism well we have it we have a
history in this country of conservative
populism and as I said at the beginning
of the show this moment could go into a
progressive populism or conservative
populism progressive pop ISM ending the
war bringing about universal health care
cracking down on the oil companies etc
etc conservative populism is I think
would tend to focus the debate more on
racism and xenophobia bashing immigrants
and more militarism either staying in
Iraq or expanding a war into Iran again
this country has a history of
conservative populism you know I I think
that are at the time we're living in now
is most analogous to the late 1970s when
you had and actually the mid 1970s
remember we had Watergate Jimmy Carter
was elected an outsider candidate
everyone thought he'd cleaned out the
government we're gonna have major change
his administration kind of stagnated the
uprising that was happening in the 70s
didn't end it was channeled by Ronald
Reagan into a conservative uprising and
the full-fledged conservative movement
and if you look at the factors today we
have similar factors a Middle East
crisis and energy crisis national
security crisis the financial meltdown
similar factors to what we had in the
late 1970s and a similar choice that our
country is going to make about which
direction to take that anger and put it
into I mean take one policy issue and
have you give an example of progressive
populism versus conservative populism
how it would play out and that's trade
policy it's a great question
progressive trade policy a progressive
populist movement on trade would say we
have to reform our trade laws to make
sure that who were trading with and how
we're trading
increases standards of living increases
environmental protection increases human
rights all over the all over the world
conservatives I think come to the table
who are who are populist on trade come
to the table saying we are we are
outsourcing our national security assets
we are outsourcing our our economic
assets that keep us strong in the world
we we we don't necessarily care that
much about the rest of the people poor
people or impoverished people and the
rest of the world this is more about
about you know there's a little bit of a
xenophobic feel to it I am Pat Buchanan
is a good example when he talks about
trade when I listened him talking about
trade he starts the first half of what
he says as I said I totally agree you
know where outsourcing our country and
where and then and then he sort of gets
into what we shouldn't help you know
help build up China or build up other
countries there's sort of that
xenophobic zeal under there and that's
that that's the double-edged sword and
how would you describe the politics of
the politicians such as Bill Clinton the
president who signed NAFTA into law well
that really gets to the US versus them
this is you know we talk about
Republicans and Democrats the Republican
Party the Democratic Party what we
really have in this country is a money
party and the people party and Bill
Clinton I think in my estimation on
policies like NAFTA was clearly a leader
of the money party big-money wanted
NAFTA but most of the country did not
and most of the country still does not
but big money controls the agenda here
in Washington and he'd that's that's
what he represented on those issues next
call for you is from Houston good
morning caller independent line hey good
morning David I look forward to reading
your book but please comment on who d
believe not only can lead the United
States but lead the world you know it's
not us against them it's about all of us
trying to come together and then also
what do you think about this election
being a total disaster from from your
perspective and I take
coming up here thank you sir well you
know ah
the focus of the book is that we
shouldn't ask one leader to lead us out
of out of the morass that in the
economic morass or in the national
security morass or in you know I think
we we have gotten used to this
paternalistic view of the of the
presidency didn't we just elect the
right person all of our problems will be
fixed I think it's much more complicated
than that
I think it's what we're gonna need to do
to make all these changes is it's going
to require a huge amount of local
organizing to not only not just elect a
president but put pressure on presidents
governor's senators Congress people
state legislatures to change their
policy what I worry about in the
election is again that we will see the
election as the end not the means that
people will say we may change we voted
for change and we're not going to stay
involved in making sure change
ultimately happens next calls from New
York City for David Sirota Republican
line yes I'd like to know if the country
is overwhelmingly against the war why
isn't McCain getting slaughtered in the
polls against Obama thank you that's a
great question I I think I think it has
to do with the with the idea that it at
a base level the country doesn't see
either party as different on the issue
of the war and unfortunately that is at
least at a certain level is absolutely
true you look at the record of both
parties on the war and what you see are
both parties voting for the war to start
the war and both parties continuing to
vote to cut checks to fund the war I
mean it is absolutely disgusting and
absurd that you have a Democratic Party
that is airing ads against John McCain
accusing him of wanting to stay in Iraq
at the same time congressional Democrats
are moving forward a bill to continue
the war indefinitely this is such
hypocrisy and I think the public
basically understands that and so why is
John McCain and why name is Brock Obama
not a head of John McCain consider
that issue I think it's cuz the public
understands it at a very base level both
parties are part of the problem right
now our next call for David's throat is
from Grand Blanc Michigan Democrats line
more good morning sir morning my name is
Dan Hanson granblade I agree a lot a lot
of what you're saying but one thing I
don't agree with is that the White House
are you next president can't make a
change which I was actually a Hillary
Clinton supporter but now I'm going to
go towards Barack Obama now that he's
got the nomination but I think a
powerful leader will write ideal and is
willing to move the country away from
the left/right you know and bring the
country together can make good changes
but well I agree I agree with you I I
agree that that a president can make
change what I'm saying is two things
first and foremost that a president
can't make change unto themselves that a
president that the history of this
country is social movements pressuring
presidents to accept change positions
that they often don't want to take want
to take one to accept social movements
forced Lyndon Johnson to pass the civil
rights movement Lyndon Johnson did not
hand down civil rights legislation out
of the benevolence of his own heart
right I mean that's the same thing for
every president FDR did not hand down
the New Deal he was forced to accept
many of the policies of the New Deal
what the second thing I'm saying though
is that beyond the presidency you know
there is a huge amount of or there is a
huge number of arenas that people can be
involved in to make huge huge changes
you know if you want to fix health care
if you want to fix tax fairness you have
everybody in this country except for I
guess Washington DC as a state
legislature right your state legislature
has a huge amount of power
I think the stat is that the state
legislatures right now control just as
much if not a little bit more tax payer
money then the federal government
does in terms of discretionary
non-defense spending many of us don't
even pay attention to our state
legislature our City Council so what I'm
saying is the you can get involved and
yes the presidency is important but
think about those arenas where you can
be even more impactful which have a huge
amount of power that often lays idle in
addition to this book the uprising you
can hear David Sirota voice in many
other places including in these Times
Magazine the nation American Prospect
and Huffington Post he's also a
full-time blogger at credo action.com he
publishes his own newsletter which you
can find out more about it David Sirota
comm and after saying all that my
question to you is why ultimately did
your career take you in the direction of
opinion journalism as opposed to
actually getting involved in grassroots
politics yourself well I started in an
opinion journalism and I actually
started in journals I went to journalism
school and then I got involved in
politics and what I found
frankly is that I started getting a
Washington I was working on the hill I
started getting feeling that the system
was rigged and then and I the name of my
chapter on the US Senate is called the
permanent barrier and that's not my term
that's Alexander Hamilton's term or the
Senate when he was justifying the
creation of a Senate we need a permanent
barrier to popular will and so what I
decided at some point and it wasn't some
epiphany moment I just sort of came to
it that that what we need but what I
wanted to do was try to expose that and
try to be a voice for that because I
think what we're suffering from at least
in the Iraq war is a great example is we
had a situation where where the public
where the journalism was telling us that
oh the serious position on the Iraq war
was to support the Iraq war and there
was no questioning of it and what I what
came out of that for me as sort of
epiphany was we need more people who are
willing to really tell the truth and
shine the light on what's going on
we social movements are really really
important grassroots organizing is
really really critical but one thing
that fuels it are people who dig up the
real truth and help sort of fan that
fire next call for you comes from
Crownsville Maryland this is a
Republican caller and you're on the air
welcome home good morning how you doing
thanks I think first off that more
people need to do what you're doing
the
the voice of the people is obviously
being muted by Washington and al-amin
state legislatures around the country my
my comment is though that I have a
question as well if you'll indulge me
you know when I was in high school
before a fight you could feel the
tension in the air whatever
confrontation would break out in between
people as it's cut through it with the
knife and that's an energy that I myself
feel every single day I mean I think I
think you're right and what you said
it's not us against them it's it's it's
us who have against us you know that
have not you know and my question is
though is you what you talked about the
anger and the in the uprising and the
people and around the country but what
specifically are people doing it and
where specifically can people go who
want to get involved and I also would
like to know why it is you think that
the politicians in this country
particularly Washington think it's
impossible for us to have a revolution
in this country like they do in other
countries all over the world when
governments become extremely oppressive
well caller you called us on the
Republican lines so you identify with
one of the major political parties what
what kind of change would you like to
see you talked about a general
frustration but put some specifics to it
we're what what do you see that you want
corrected about the fun thing well first
off I'd like to see you know the process
in the Congress in the Senate it's very
cumbersome and slow and again there's a
place where the voice of the people can
be muted and and we have no recourse I'd
like to see things like what happens on
state referendums take take place at the
federal level I'd like to see quicker
enactment of accountability standards
against these politicians I mean the
people should be able to go and vote and
if X amount of people 51 percent of the
people want you know such-and-such out
of office then that should be done
without all the bureaucratic red tape
and loopholes one more specific excuse
me for interrupting but and talk about
an issue that was important to you where
you felt the voice of the public was
muted in Washington the prescription
drug bill that just was enacted by what
two years ago three years ago you know
the people had no say-so on that and
we had no recourse I mean the the
elections are somewhat of a joke it's
you know I mean they put up the
candidates they prop up the candidates
they fund the candidates they invent the
issues is the whole agenda is controlled
by a handful of people in power and the
people are virtually ignored immigration
would be another issue you know the most
most of Americans don't hate Latinos or
anybody else it's just the fact that a
handful of people are profiting
along with these corporations at the
expense of us and our children and our
grandchildren and the things that our
ancestors have built in this country are
being sold to the highest bidder just
curious what do you do in Crownsville
Maryland I'm sorry what do you do for a
living you're a truck driver
yeah I'm looking I'm looking to be in
public office okay thank you for
participating this morning yeah that was
it that was a great a great question a
great bunch of questions grew things you
can do to be involved not to sound like
a broken record if you want to be
involved in electoral politics you can
run for office you run through local
office if you want to be involved lower
down than the candidate or underneath
the candidate you can be involved in in
campaigning for volunteering for your
state legislative candidate your City
Council candidate but I have to
interrupt you you tried that and you
said that the system no well what I said
was that what that when I was in
Washington and local governments are
more responsive I absolutely think they
are I'm on the board right now and I've
founded the progressive states Network
which works with state legislators all
over the country that's where I've still
put my I've taken a little chunk of my
free time and put it into into
organizing still organizing state
legislators but when I was going to say
is that is it beyond that if you want to
get involved in direct action taking
matters really into your own hands and
this is a thing that that we've sort of
lost track of in our country what is
direct action direct action is stuff
like trying to unionize your workplace
getting involved in the shareholder
activism movement or gonna and
shareholder activism if you if you have
two thousand dollars worth of stock you
can file a shareholder resolution
against the company if you don't have
two thousand dollars but you have some
in your 401k you can vote your shares of
stock you can use the internet to organ
around issues - pressure whatever levels
of government you want and I again I
would suggest starting at the local
level so there's many many things to get
involved in in fact there's an infinite
number of things to get involved in and
my book is only a taste of that I agree
with you that that that there is a lack
of accountability and that the sense of
helplessness is really really profound
and that's why I think that it as people
choose issues to organize around it's
important to try to organize around
structural issues now they're the
hardest to organize around because they
seem a little bit distant from the the
momentary issues of the day but let me
give you an example public financing of
Elections every single issue that
Congress the president state
legislatures City Council's deal with
ultimately has something to do with
public financing of Elections because
public financing of Elections is who
does the candidate originally get money
from to get into office because that's
in part who they feel like they answer
to so organizing around trying to create
public financing systems so that
candidates could run for office without
relying on money that comes with the
expectation of legislative favors that
is a key issue how do you react then to
the regular rulings by the Supreme Court
that political contributions are a
matter of speaking Oh
public financing systems I think are
they get around that rule II and not
even get around they don't have much to
do with that really that ruling says you
can't limit somebody's right to spend
whatever they want on their own campaign
public financing systems in Arizona
Connecticut they basically say they
fight money with money if you run and
you qualify by raising a certain number
of small donations you're entitled to a
bigger public financing of your campaign
and if you're running against somebody
at least in Arizona if you're running
against somebody who uses that Supreme
Court ruling to spend lots of money on
their race there's a certain matching
fund so that at least you can you can go
one to one on spending against your
opponent so that there's an equal
playing field eight minutes left with
david sirota next telephone calls from
Charlottesville Virginia independent
line good morning hi thank you for
taking my call
I appreciate your spirit sir one two
third I observed a three-hour hearing on
the rising oil prices and energy markets
which was chaired by Senator Maria
Cantwell and the blinders came off
concerning the attack on our economy as
well as their national security and now
I realize that it is Congress that bears
the full responsibility for the current
state of our republic the deregulation
by the commodities future Trading
Commission that created a dark market
allowing manipulation of the markets
with misleading information and insider
trading made possible by the end and Ron
loopholes created by the first template
permits have been issued since 2004 for
drilling on yeah for our resources which
I can't understand why that's not being
pursued in a responsible way but China
is doing it hoarding supplies and
blocking production drives their prices
up while they're being sheltered through
current loopholes and we absolutely need
vigilance on the part of our citizens
it's our responsibility according to the
Constitution and I would love to see not
only transparency and accountability but
about abolition of sovereign immunity
that protects how can I say it the the
greedy public servants that we've
elected into office it seems that they
put their personal interests ahead of
the interest of our nation thank you
color well I I think you're right I I
think I'm glad you mentioned Congress's
culpability here on this crisis
ultimately corporations are going to do
whatever they can to make as much money
as they can that's their role in a
capitalist society
the fault when a corporation or a set of
corporations gets out of control like
the oil companies charging people for
dollars for 5454 gas while making 40
billion dollars in one year like Exxon
Mobil the problem is that Congress
hasn't stepped in to make sure that the
energy market actually works for the
most Americans right that's the problem
it's not that Exxon Mobil doesn't have
enough money and they need to raise
prices in order to to barely make a
profit right we're talking with the
largest profits in the history of
corporations and so what that really
says is that our government is not doing
what it needs to be doing and that's
what this uprising that's what this
backlash is fundamentally all about
people realizing in a fundamental way
maybe nylund's all the specific issues
but in a fundamental way that our
government has abdicated its
responsibility to make sure that the
economy works for everybody
Tallahassee good morning Stella Florida
good morning I want to ask this question
why is it that the American people don't
know the real reason why we're in a war
in Iraq because for me reason number one
was the Sabathia debacle of the 2000
election were in the Supreme Court
placed the president in office reason
number two was the upcoming election 404
therefore the people were distracted by
a war in Iraq in oh three reason number
four was to take over the resources and
the oil fields in Iraq why don't the
American people know the real reason why
we're there
thank you color I think it's because we
live in a culture of fear every time you
turn on the television you're being told
to be afraid and in the lead-up to war
there was a case being made by our
government and the media that the Iraq
war was about stopping al Qaeda when of
course we know that that's not the case
that had nothing to do with it factually
substantively why the better question I
think though is why is the war not alive
we haven't been able to stop the war
right and I think it has a lot to do
with the anti-war uprisings
decisions you'll notice that most of the
anti-war uprisings focus has been on
trying to attack and pressure
Republicans even though Democrats
control Congress as I say in the book
that has a lot to do with conflicts of
interests at the heart of the anti-war
uprising the organizations that are
leading the anti-war uprising many of
them are also affiliated with the
Democratic Party that they could be and
should be pressuring and so the one of
the reasons the war continues to go on
is because the strategy for stopping it
actually has helped perpetuate it
Longview Texas good morning for David
Sirota Republican line you're on the air
yes sir it's nice to hear someone talk
about independent populism and
grassroots movement enough time where
our government is completely
unresponsive I just wanted to say though
sir I take some issue with your early
mention to what you described is kind of
a conservative populist movement I mean
I've noticed like for instance people
often paint Lou Dobbs on CNN as a racist
when in fact they obviously know nothing
about his background he's fluent in
Spanish and is married to a Hispanic
who's an immigrant and you know I just
kind of wonder sometimes that assumption
somewhat creeps in there obviously are
racist in the conservative movement
there's also racism the progressive
movement and a type that kind of attacks
the ik radix sort of mentality so I just
wanted to address that issue that
sometimes we one of the reasons changes
their problems there's a temptation to
demonize people who disagree so I just
wanted to make that comment or thank you
sir
well the I think you're right that there
are there is racism on both sides I
think that that a lot of the the
immigration issue actually stems from
xenophobia a fear of everything else a
fear of the other I've had this debate
with Lou Dobbs and I think that you know
Lou Don I have it in the book with him
the issue is that what I have a problem
with Lou Dobbs and it shows you how
we're divided he talks about free trade
and then he demagogues immigration I
agree with him on free trade I disagree
with the way he talks about immigration
but the problem is that he never make
melds the - he never shows how free
trade a failed trade policy exacerbates
poverty in Mexico
which then creates immigration pressure
what I said to Lou Dobbs is look you
know you build a ten-foot wall at the
border and all you're doing is creating
an eleven archit four 11-foot ladders if
you don't address the problem and I
think the demagoguery is seeking the
reason he demagogues it and he's a smart
guy the reason he and other people
demagogue the issue and don't make that
connection I think is to tap into that
anger that xenophobic anger so I agree
with you I I don't think Lou Dobbs is a
racist and I don't think anybody
everybody who has a problem with our
immigration policies a racist not not by
a longshot but what I say is is that
that leaders of a conservative populist
movement sometimes try to tap into that
and that's what I think we should be
afraid of for ratings or to effect
change I think it's I think it's a
little bit of both I mean I think you
know sometimes you want to tap into the
most white hot passionate part of the
electorate because that's the part that
can actually that will actually motivate
to make change I also think I also think
it sure it has to do with you know media
and television ratings I'll then what
Lou Dobbs would say is if I went into my
head in my editor if I was a young
couple I went into my editor and said
I'm gonna cover free trade and
immigration and and the war on the
middle class is the way to get ratings
he said my editor when I was a cub
reporter would have thrown me out of the
office and fired me squeeze in one last
questions from Mayfield Kentucky
independent line good morning good
morning I'm a school teacher at these
social studies and we in our class
instead of following the textbook we
talk about real solutions to like the
energy crisis the hydrogen economy
entitlement reform and stuff that kids
ask me once you run for Congress and the
reason that element is true for a lot of
people is to break the power of an
incumbent you have to be able to to run
for Congress for like two years without
doing anything else and like everybody
else I got a bunch of clock I have a job
mortgage and so on and it's it's darn
near impossible to break the part of
incumbency without having a lot of money
that you can sit on or a business that
you can sit on and let somebody else
write for you while you run for Congress
so I like to hear your thoughts on this
thank you you're absolutely right look
Congress has become a millionaire's club
and I think it's precisely because of
what you talked about
incumbency has become a huge problem
both through redistricting redistricting
is tended to make districts safer so
that the races are Lessing less
competitive the individual races are
less competitive consolidation of the
media has meant that you know the best
thing for an incumbent is to never be
covered by the media at all because then
the Challenger will never be covered
either and people will just vote for who
they know and so as the median is
consolidated and cut back on reporting
that has helped solidify incumbents even
more not to sound like a broken record
but to go back to the issue of
structural reform to break that you need
redistricting reform and you mean we
need organizing around public financing
elections which many of the groups in
the book that I did I outlined in the
book are actually organizing around and
have had and it's taken a long time but
have had some success and you've got
public financing systems in conservative
states like Arizona and more progressive
states like Connecticut
it can't happen and when it does it will
fundamentally change this country it
will really help Express the uprising in
terms of I think positive public policy
we've been showing it to you but we'll
do it one last time the book is called
the uprising and it is available widely
in bookstores in your neighborhood or
online David Sirota is the author and
the man who traveled America for the
last year to talk to the grassroots
thank you for being here to talk to
c-span this morning thanks for having me